the Game of Thrones people those aren't
real dragons the dopest fuck did you
watch last night I didn't I did was
again spoiler alert it was awesome oh
yeah awesome just to see everything I
just want to see it I was happy to see a
new episode I'm gonna be so sad when
that show gets canceled I'm such a dork
you've watched it all the way happen
about doing the prequel or the the
beginning of it were serious but they
haven't okay man whoever the fucking
people other doing it just keep doing
things whoever those people that are
writing and producing it and putting it
together and and keep hiring those
actors to play different people I don't
care I lost my way after like maybe
three seasons how many seasons is AB
anomaly fuck up you lost your way go
back and start from scratch and learn
all the names of these places and the
make-believe face on show and whatever
is how much do I have to know Joe I know
well you know how to make bread just
keep making a delicious bread I do and
you do it simple yeah a martini a little
bread one of your life
yeah jog how much why do I look tough I
do I have to control every match I would
like enough oh catch back up with it
yeah it's good right people like it so
you're gonna like let this whole season
play by without you being caught up
I almost last night was just gonna watch
just jump it jump in who cares if
there's any show that you never get like
please tell me he gave up on the walking
dead yes thank you yeah I stopped that
one is there any show that you haven't
give up huh that you've been steadfast
that I stick whatever you binge do you
still watch uh do you haven't quit no
there's none that I'm currently watching
I just watch Russian doll what is that
that's on Netflix that was good that
girls are gonna Sasson or something no
she's she's uh she dies every episode
it's like Groundhog Day yeah it was
pretty good
and now I've seen all the big ones Ozark
Ozark yeah one season of it you didn't
wash easy - no was I supposed to
I don't know how you just shut it off
you don't want to know what happened I
don't know I forget
[Laughter]